here is my issue with this whole
steroidal for them to take anything that
was performance-enhancing right there
pull it up go ahead for them to take
anything that was performance-enhancing
during their time in baseball was not
illegal it was not outside of the
purview of the rules at that time so how
is it and this is the thing that pisses
me off is because they they always talk
about putting an asterisk right right
next to their nose in baseball at that
time it was not illegal to take any
performance-enhancing anything is that
true it was not a right it was not
illegal
he's right here it's hundred percent
he's right okay so I have a legal mouth
add this the pictures were taking not in
the league in oh three is when they made
it as a law in the NBA rule to say in
MLB as a rule to say you can use all one
or oh three matter of fact go little
closer and now go search on a different
page don't go on this mug wanna set a
different page and say what year did
Sammy Sosa use steroids okay but go
ahead so so it was not illegal to be
using steroids okay
yes baseball so at the time when that
happened it wasn't like it was against
them being able to use it yeah so why in
the world would we penalize somebody
because they're doing something to the
best of their ability within the purview
of the rules at that time and let's be
honest that is that Homer this mic is
limp just so you guys know that that
home run race is the one that saved
baseball because baseball you know what
we should give a shout-out to our
incoming sponsor because what what a
great segue but I think we'll say that
for the next episode look so yes or no
you're saying yes they should definitely
be in the Hall of Fame they saved
baseball should those guys be in the
Hall of Fame
yeah for sure Paul you
are you kid you don't know his career
numbers like what do you tell my courier
number 580 home runs and his crew you
two guys got him yes without a doubt
yeah do you know I have a one of my best
friends failed out of college because he
didn't go to any classes in 1999 because
he was obsessed with the home run race
he missed every single class and just
stayed home watching the home run race
and I said dude what how do you fail he
was obsessed you'd I'll never forget the
moment that home run barely clears the
fence barely when Mark McGwire hit it it
was like a line drive but it barely
clears the fence and I'll never forget I
still see it he comes home and when he
gets home he lifts his boy the first
thing is his teammates don't do anything
they let him get to his boy he lifts his
boy up I haven't had my testosterone
showing this short shot in a few weeks
so later about a second but he lives his
boy up and dude I don't know if you've
ever actually seen McGuire's forearms in
person or anything his forearms are as
big as my calf dude I mean they're like
19 inches are of around huge okay like
this is Priester 49 home runs in his
rookie season how do you get 49 home
runs in your rookie season he's a beast
so you're saying he belongs in for sure
so let me ask you a different question
here's a completely different question
for you here's a complete different
question for you okay by the way just so
you know it shows all three is when he
got tested positive so they don't know
what you're so say you steroids and if
you look at social stats in 1993 Sosa
hit 33 home runs and 93 RBIs pull up the
stats again go back to 1993 sauce at the
second one over there go to the right
top right the second link reference go
there and go to zoom in a little bit
zoom in a little bit look in 1993 season
1993 season Sosa hit 33 home runs
oh these pads of your sky are you like
ok you need a 1983 33 home runs 93 RBIs
36 stolen bases the guy had a good
season that year think about the stats
this guy is a all-star MVP and 95 95 is
way before here - 66 or months now look
at that 90
66 99 63 that dude the only guy that
hits 60 home runs three times in his
career Paul that's not 60 times three
times in his career career homers was
how many you got six hundred and nine
home runs Paul how many people have at
six hundred items are so this is my
argument this my this my argument with
the steroids in baseball so for me when
the whole thing start like in the early
nineties when you went to school if a
kid smoke weed what you think about him
he's a pothead here's a pothead right
okay let me ask you another thing in
high school when you and I were in
junior high school okay it's on your 12
mid 90s you saw a guy tatted up what you
think about them tatted up had it up
would you think about what souls
McGuire's IVC McGuire's a physician is
yes no not not no Maguire first six five
yet hide his different story I know he
was 33 93 in 1993 look at his type and
said typing sammy sosa body in 1993 but
let me go back to you okay you're 13
years old you go to the mall with your
mom okay you walk into the mall and you
see a guy with a tank top on tattoos
everywhere yeah what did you what did
your immediate area because I would have
been scared of who is that guy remember
what is it today you're an average
millennial you're an average millennial
today with tattoos yeah why what
happened because tattoos went from
gangsters to art their shifts to
mainstream mainstream because rappers
started I mean Michael Jordan does he
have any tattoos this many tattoo yeah
how many tattoos does LeBron have how
many tattoos Kobe hair right yeah it's a
complete difference art bright now right
let's not a gangster
now get it so so what's the point -
here's the mess the point I'm trying to
make you is falling what is wheat today
what is real what is weed today what is
wheat is pop culture it's having a beer
not a beer that's right I don't smoke
weed myself the last time I smoked weed
I was it was
while back when I smoke weed but it's
probably a good thing I should smoke
weed for me a lot of people would
probably like me to smoke weed every
pastor we thank well watch I'm gonna go
to church one day you're gonna start
smoking we hear there here's the
question the real question is what if
they made it something were if you
choose to use it and they made it open
to everybody because if you think for a
second in the game of NFL guys are not
using stuff you're an absolute fool of
you think guys in the FS in the NFL now
you're saying if you think in the game
of the NFL guys are not using steroids
you are naive if I'm nothing there
there's using some sort of performance
in hands there is no question to you
have you but here's the thing I
understand why you would use it it's
like saying bodybuilding if you think
bodybuilders are not doing everything
under the Sun of course you're out of
your mind if you're thinking that right
okay so what if they did
what's wrong if they're using it so hey
Jim just what's wrong if what's wrong if
in Major League Baseball they said if
you want to use if you want to go out
and put trt sipping sipping a you want
to put equipoise you want to put
whatever you want to put on your body if
it helps you guess what more power to
you what if they do that gimme NFL in
MLB by the way here's the argument to
that you ready here's the argument to
that you benefit from that using it
listen to what I'm saying to you there
is a benefit to not using it there's not
just a benefit if you use it because
when you bulk up some people bulk up
they'll chest is up you can't do your
full swing you could go like this like a
baseball you could go like this when the
chest gets too big your arms go like
this you don't have the tight swing like
you would normally have right so this
whole life like in basketball it's not
good to be bit it's not so the point is
that the point that yet recovery fine
but the point is that just because
you're using it it doesn't mean it helps
you it doesn't mean it helps everybody
else so then there comes an argument to
say okay so what is wrong because right
now the arguments be coming with Meryl
to be illegal in the NBA what do you
think about that I don't care I know a
lot of NBA players they smoked what up
but what I'm saying is who cares if
they're using we'd let them use weed if
they're playing if they want to smoke
weed do you think you think so you're
saying whether this whatever sport is
it's okay to look the other way if
they're using no no no not look the
other way not at all I'm not telling you
look the other way I'm telling you if a
guy plays a game okay and you saw the
last dance where Michael Jones is when I
first came to the Bulls it was called
the Chicago coke kids or whatever NIC
them a lot of the guys got pissed Iran
can smoke under a napkin coke I'm not
because coke is not legal there is no
debate talking about coke being legal
coke is man-made marijuana is God made
it's natural it's a different argument I
can make for it so it's an IV so is
poison ivy I get that but the point I'm
trying but the point I'm trying to make
is if in the NBA they make weed legal
smoke weed do you have a problem with
that hey so I actually do have some
friends that play in the NFL and they
actually tell me some crazy stories okay
so they all get pee testing right and so
they actually tell the stories
themselves like it started with them
having to go in and they would have to
come out with a sample Cup but then
obviously guys started sneaking n P you
know from and they'd fill the sample cup
they'd bring it out so they switched it
to where a guy has to go in and he has
to stand there and you got to go to
urinal and and you know do your stuff so
what guys what guys started doing was
Clorox no they would get these fake
appendages yeah and they would fill them
with urine and then they would plop it
out so we have the fake decks yeah yeah
and and then they would squeeze the
urine into said cup and so now you
literally have to drop trou right in
front of the guy I think I'll be done in
the army by the way you told me that's
the army when we got tested every week
this is how it was luck in the army they
would say if your social ends with a
number two step out and you would step
up you guys are getting tested if your
social ends with zero step out if your
last four starts with the number one
step on you step out and you go upstairs
and they're lined up and you would go
literally standard 2p and they're
looking at you looking at you who's
litter sergeant's looked men dread on
right over your shoulder 100% right here
they're looking at you okay go you got
it good okay good that's it and what
they were looking for is that you didn't
take one of these cups to have what he
call it
Clorox bleach because if it touches a
little bit you put it in there boom
you're coming out clean so so what a lot
of guys would do they would put the
squirt it would always have a little bit
on here and your pian you put a little
bit of that in there they can't pull up
the weed it's done it doesn't come up
yeah okay so so you put a little bleach
or Clorox yes looking for a new job what
they did in the military's they started
looking and they said okay go ahead and
put your left hand over here take it out
okay ball P great got it so it wasn't
cuz you would want to put your thumb at
your finger in there to want to mix it
up and I know this because our unit our
unit was sponsored by weed is pretty
much right there every time six engineer
they should have called this a 420
engineer unit dinner because everybody
was high so go back yeah what's the
problem if you let everybody use juice
and it's open to everybody and it's an
open thing well my thing is if we talk
about the Maguire's in the sauce but so
were the pitchers right the guy's
pitching to the hitters so they're quite
fun right they're bigger fabulous
elements is the big he Clemens belongs
in the league he just was an [ __ ] and
he pissed people off hey man bonds
belong there just started a little bit
they they they put my people off here
spit I'm alone so who has not made the
Hall of Fame that totally should have
been in the Hall of Fame Barry Bonds
that have juiced or just in general yeah
right I mean that of jus Heath Roses the
biggest name of course 4340 Long's in it
okay okay you got lawns McGwire no sir
Rafael Palmeiro Roger Clemens O'Meara
Palmeiro is a 50 home run yeah there's a
320 hitter so you got you got you got a
bunch of these are all names who have
not made it into the hole should be of
course they should yeah but they've not
none of them are in none of them are in
what about what about what about Juan
Gonzalez is he in yeah I don't think one
is in because one also juiced
of course one was your hero sir hero
these guys all juiced yeah I'll just
remind you guys it was not illegal at
that time just allow me to drive that
point home too so yeah I mean there's no
problem with them doing that during that
period here's here's one thing that I
think sucks for for some of these guys
is they'll take some sort of substance
or something that they don't even know
has something illegal in it or will test
them a certain way and there's some of
these guys that are losing out on huge
contracts based on the fact that like I
don't know if this is a wives tale but I
think it's true that you can eat a poppy
seed muffin and test positive for
marijuana right yeah that sounds like a
Seinfeld episode no no true but that was
yeah
poppy seed muffin you can eat how are we
knocking on your seed muffin Sammy
Sosa's skin are we just gonna skip right
over that no no let's come back to his
skin but you can eat a poppy seed muffin
and you can test positive the same way
that you can chew okay oh yeah so the
same way that you can chew and they've
proven this now too you can chew gum and
then blow breathalyzer yeah
the PM extract is used to make open
drugs such as morphine codeine and
heroin there you go yeah
so those of you that are gonna be taking
a drug test don't be in an epoxy bagel
speaking of drugs Josh you've never
sampled anything nothing nothing you
never had a sip of alcohol in your life
never I'm just gonna leave that there
never never never now let me ask you was
it parents a fear of not using like
God's watching you if you commit a sin
like this or what what was it that made
you not want to use it so a couple of
reasons so obviously I grew up in a
religious conservative households
definitely played into it number two my
dad actually worked at a winery and if
so we would go to drop him off at work
and if you smell the fermentation
process that alcohol goes through and
you're exposed to that and
naturally disgust you but then thirdly
my great-grandmother was actually taken
in a drunk driving accident and so it's
just kind of a combination
great-grandmother yeah so my what is
that in the 1880s grandma I got hit by a
horse a horse and a buggy
so dad if you're listening we're really
sorry about your grandmother passing
away Adam is so distraught over here
this way your grandma you know okay but
great-grandma and then 1890s cross it
got a wagon the horse was drunk someone
yeah the Oregon Trail Josh's mom comes
Wow wait to see Wow so that's why that's
so like I think it was a combination of
did anybody will come up come up to
stand here try some weed smoke some weed
oh yeah yeah many times yeah and you
said no said no every scene alcohol try
some Josh I've so looked i've never even
smoked a cigarette never smoked a cigar
never had alcohol and I've only been
with one woman yeah
[Music]